les vendanges se terminent cyrille
devaud s'est rendu à bagnols ce afin de
savoir si la cuvée 98 prochaine sera de
bonne tenue reportage ou en couleur la
star dan c'est plus une danse c'est
l'âme de tout le pays catalan sous le
soleil du roussillon elles rythment la
vie des habitants comme ici à banny ce
week end sur la place du village
on fêtait les vents dans ce plus haut
sur les côtes haut-pyrénéens là où les
vignobles en terrasses semble se jeter
dans la méditerranée
les enfants ont également danser la
sardane
car ces élèves de cm1 et cm2 possède
deux aussi leur carré de vigne
une soixantaine d'art donnée par la
mairie qu'ils ont planté soigner
sulfater afin d'en vendanger le raisin
grenache à l'aide de leurs papilles des
vignerons retraités qui leur
transmettent les techniques
traditionnelles
ils n'ont que 10 ou 11 ans mais le
raisin n'a déjà plus aucun secret pour
eux car le vignoble
c'est le symbole de cette culture
catalane légué par les anciens chaque
papier à ses gosses et puis le plus ce
qu'il fait le plus plaisir c'est que
quand on se balade en ville en attaque
et lequel guy papy gaby vendanges porté
à dos de mulet puis béni par le curé
tout effet selon la tradition un rituel
immuable depuis le xiiie siècle
c'est un nid pour cela que le précieux
nectar le fameux vin doux naturel de
banyuls conserve la même saveur de
génération en génération